The A to Z of -isms...
transhumanism.
Most of us would consider the end
of the human race as a catastrophe.
There are some however
who would not only rejoice at it
but want to hasten the day it arrives.
Transhumanists look forward to a future
in which Homo sapiens
is superseded by a better,
smarter, fitter model -
humanity 2.0.
Humans are in dire need of improvement.
Any species that causes
huge damage to our environment,
can't feed itself
even though it has enough food
and fights countless wars
costing millions of lives
must surely benefit
from an intelligence upgrade.
Our lifespans are short,
our final years usually characterised
by diminishing health and vitality,
often accompanied
by a drop off in cognitive capacity.
One in three people born in 2015
are expected to get dementia.
Is this really the best we can hope for?
Transhumanists think not.
Ageing could be stopped
and even reversed.
Enhancements
could dramatically raise our IQs
and make us stronger and fitter.
We might even be able
to leave our fragile bodies behind
and upload ourselves to computers,
living forever in virtual worlds.
Improving humanity
through science and technology
could radically change us.
Such a new beginning would in effect
be the end of humanity as we know it.
Many transhumanists see this
as not only desirable but inevitable.
The scientist and futurist, Ray Kurzweil,
believes we are approaching
what he calls "the singularity" -
the point at which computers become
smart enough to learn for themselves,
after which they will rapidly
become smarter and smarter.
The future belongs
to artificial intelligence.
The only way for humanity to survive
is to embrace it
and become
wholly or partially artificial ourselves.
The thought of being replaced
by a new form of humanity
is bound to be unsettling.
But transhumanists think
we would be wrong to lament
the end of humanity as we know it
when what replaces us
would be so much better.
It would be like wishing
children never grew up
or that Homo erectus never evolved
into Homo sapiens.
If the transhumanists are right,
we could be one of the last generations
of humans to roam the planet.
Thanks for watching.
Don't forget to subscribe and click the bell to receive notifications for new videos.
See you again soon!